hello everybody just point get started I
will say that this is not a normal
biographic video we don't normally put
out content on a Friday so this is just
a bit of extra bonus stuff for you this
video on Neil Armstrong was actually one
I did for another channel I do called
highlight history I'm linking to that
below if you like this and would like to
check out more the whole video is here
so I'm not gonna stop it halfway through
and say yeah I got to go over to the
other channel and watch the rest the
whole video is here so you can enjoy it
in its fullness and if you really like
it do please go subscribe to highlight
history that would be fantastic it's all
over today in history things that I do
and let's get into it after undergoing
cardiac bypass surgery in August of 2012
Neil Armstrong seemed to be recovering
just fine at which point reportedly some
of his nurses removed wires that have
been temporarily attached to his
pacemaker what followed was internal
bleeding which in turn led doctors to
drain the blood instead of choosing to
operate to stop the bleeding ultimately
he died today in history August the 25th
2012 at the age of 82 what followed was
a legal battle that eventually saw the
hospital threatened with having the
details of the lawsuit publicized if
they didn't pay a settlement the
hospital then gave in with some among
armstrong's family receiving portions of
a 6 million dollar settlement for
alleged malpractice on the part of the
hospital workers the details of what
exactly occurred in Armstrong's last
days have largely been kept out of the
public eye owing to a non-disclosure
agreement as a stipulation of the
settlement Lance Armstrong's wife Carol
was very public about her opposition of
the lawsuit in the first place
noting Neil would not have approved of
it with Carol further saying in an
interview I wasn't part of it I want
that for the record whatever happens
exactly after Armstrong's death then
President Obama stated Neil was among
the greatest of American heroes not just
of his time but of all time when he and
his fellow crew members lifted off
aboard Apollo 11 in 1969 they carried
with them the aspirations of an entire
nation they set out to show the world
that the American spirit can see beyond
what seems unimaginable that with enough
Drive and ingenuity anything is possible
and when Neil stepped foot on the
surface of the Moon for the first time
he delivered a moment of human
achievements that will never be
forgotten so how did Neil Armstrong come
to be
one of the most legendary explorers in
human history
well Valle enough it will start with his
late application being clandestinely
slipped into the application pile when
it technically should never have been
you see Armstrong turned his application
into NASA about a week after the 1st of
June 1962 deadline making him ineligible
for that historic second round of
astronaut hirings luckily for Armstrong
dick day who was the one who encouraged
Armstrong to apply in the first place
and was working at NASA as an assistant
head of flight crew operations
clandestinely slipped Armstrong's
application into the candidate resume
folders before the applications were
reviewed by the selection panel said day
I really didn't know why Neel delayed
his application but he did and all the
applications came to me since I was
there to Flight Creek training but he
had done so many things so well at
Edwards he was so far and away the best
qualified more than any other certainly
as compared to the first group of
astronauts we that's day and what
Williams wanted him in it has been
speculated since whether accurately or
not as anyone's guess that the lateness
of the application never had something
to do with Armstrong's two-year-old
daughter Karen tragically dying just a
few months earlier from complications
due to a tumor that was growing on a
brainstem whatever the case as for his
qualifications Armstrong Leben of pilots
at 16 years old and ultimately flew a
whopping 78 combat missions during the
Korean War in one mission he had part of
a wing sheared off by a cable booby-trap
about 500 feet above the ground all
while under heavy fire he managed to
keep the plane in the air long enough to
get away but eventually he had to eject
at which point he was rescued by a
fellow Navy flyer in a jeep far enough
during college beyond writing and
directing to musicals on the side he
earns both a Bachelors of Science in
aeronautical engineering and later a
Masters of Science in aerospace
engineering he followed all of that up
by becoming a test pilot flying over 200
different aircraft models including the
rocket-powered variety in the process
quickly becoming considered one of the
top pilots in the world out of a group
of 29 astronauts that trained for the
Apollo mission to the moon only three
were chosen for the first plans moon
landing when the final announcement was
made in January of 1969 Neil Armstrong
Edwin Buzz Aldrin and the oft forgotten
Michael Collins became the official crew
of Apollo 11 immediately attention to
which crew member Armstrong or Aldrin
would be
first to walk on the moon Collins was
the command module pilot and therefore
he was ineligible even though both men
were going to walk on the moon it was a
great honor to be the first in fact this
question was asked at that press
conference and the response was that it
had yet to be decided over the next four
months as the astronauts continued their
training debate and rumors circulated
among the media first it seems like
Aldrin would have the honor this
speculation came from the precedent set
by the Gemini program which made 10
crewed flights for the purpose of
testing ships and astronauts to
spacewalk during the flights the
commander which Armstrong was to be for
Apollo 11 stayed inside the ship while
the pilots which Aldrin was to be on
Apollo 11 did the space walking further
fueling this thinking was that it was
rumored that Aldrin was actively
campaigning to be the guy according to
the memoir written by Chris Kraft head
of Mission Control Buzz Aldrin
desperately wanted that honor and wasn't
quiet in letting it be known in April
they need three months before liftoff it
was announced that Neil Armstrong will
be the first man to walk on the moon the
main reason the NASA gave for this
decision was that the Eagles hatch opens
to one side rather than up and down and
that side who is towards the pilot
Aldrin the bottom line was that when the
hatch was opens the commander Armstrong
had a clear path to exit while the pilot
was pinned in the rather cramped space
of the module by sheer happenstance it
made more sense for Armstrong to exit
first Plus since NASA's heads pointed
out Armstrong was actually the more
senior member of the team anyway having
entered the program in 1962 while Aldrin
joined in 1963 in later years despite
the official hatch story some including
Kraft and fellow astronaut al bean have
come out and said that NASA wanted
Armstrong to have this honor
rather than Aldrin because they thought
Neil's ego could handle it better than
Aldrin it's therefore speculated that
maybe the app design was just the excuse
that NASA was looking for whatever the
case when he stepped out onto the moon
Armstrong spoke some of the most famous
words in the history of mankind
or triathlete Samantha so true so
brilliant so inspirational yes so
contradictory I mean the word man and
mankind are used synonymously meaning
that the oh so famous quote quite simply
put was that's one small step for man
one giant leap for man which makes no
sense so well what is going on here Neal
a one lettered indefinite article is all
it would take to turn this quote into
the inspirational words our brains or
process when we hear them and that
article is a one small step for a man
one giant leap for mankind
that is how most people interpret his
words and according to Neil Armstrong
those are the words that he intended to
speak NASA's official transcript of the
quote still shows the a in parentheses
that's one small step for a in
parentheses man one giant leap for
mankind this is because the a is not
audible in the broadcast for years both
NASA and Armstrong insisted that static
had obscured the a Armstrong in self
stated that he would never make such a
mistake omitting such an important part
but after listening to recordings of his
quote he finally conceded that it's
possible he may not have set the a when
he admitted this he stated I would hope
that history would grant me leeway for
dropping the syllable and understands
that it was certainly intended even if
it was not said although it might
actually have been an australian-based
computer program and named Peter Shann
Ford conducted an audio analysis to
support Armstrong's claim that he did
say a and concluded that he did in fact
say a man but but the a was inaudible
due to technological limitations of the
time however linguists David beaver and
smartly bourbon wrote their own digital
audio analysis of the infamous quote on
that language log blog and concluded
that the acoustic evidence seems to be
against Ford's theory but that's not the
end of the story support for Armstrong
has been found by a team of researchers
from Michigan State University and Ohio
State University who have concluded that
Armstrong did indeed speak the words he
claims to have spoken that static or
technological limitations not to blame
for its apparent and mission according
to them it's Armstrong's a hyoeun accent
that's to blame according to a Michigan
State University specialist in
communicative sciences assistant
professor Laura Diller because of the
dialect of his home
town if Neil Armstrong's voice did use
the word a it was short and fully
acoustically blended with the preceding
word for the acoustical Society of
America's article on this topic states
that dilly and her colleagues who
include MSU linguist Melissa Bayes Burke
and OSU psychologist mark Pitt
thought they might be able to figure out
what Armstrong said with a statistical
analysis of the duration of the our
sound as spoken by native central
hyeon's saying for and for a in natural
conversation they used a collection of
recordings of conversational speech from
forty people raised in Columbus Ohio
near Armstrong's native town of Webb
kanita
within this body of recordings they
found 191 cases of 4a they matched each
of these to an instance of four as said
by the same speaker and compared the
relative duration they also examined the
duration of Armstrong's for a from the
lunar transmission the researchers found
a large overlap between the relative
duration of the are sounds in four and
four a using the Ohio speech data the
duration of the FRA in Armstrong's
recording was 0.12 seven seconds which
falls into the middle of this overlap
there it is a slightly better match for
an a less four in other words the
researchers concludes the lunar landing
quote is highly compatible with either
possible interpretation though it is
probably slightly more likely to be
perceived as four regardless of what
Armstrong actually set dilly says there
may have been a perfect storm of
conditions for the word a to have been
spoken but not hurt this all might have
you wondering if Armstrong had
previously planned his famous line or if
it came to him while he was sitting on
the moon even until his last breath in
2012 Armstrong adamantly insisted that
his first line was spontaneous and was
only settled on in the moments prior to
the walk a BBC documentary released
after the astronauts death disputes this
thing in the film Dean Armstrong Neil's
brother tells the story of a note pass
during a late-night game of Risk nobody
can say that astronauts don't out a
party but seriously though one dude
definitely did if you want to learn more
about him check out our video Don Draper
in a spacesuit on our today I found out
channel for more on that anyway in the
months leading up to the mission Dean
Neil and the family spent time together
at Cape Court after both men put their
boys to bed and Neil challenged his
younger brother to a
a game of Risk during that game Neal
handed Dean a piece of paper on that
piece of paper there was that's one
small step for a man one giant leap for
mankind
he says what do you think about that I
said fabulous he says I thought you
might like that but I wanted you to read
it that said both Aldrin and Collins
made it clear that at no point did
Armstrong share his thoughts on what he
would say with them of course
perhaps his brother was the exception
although given the second thing he said
on the moon was far less eloquent
seemingly there was at least some prat
as for that second thing according to
the official Apollo 11 air-to-ground
voice transcription it was and the
surface is fine and powdery Armstrong
continued on this line of thinking I can
pick it up loosely with my toe it does
it here in fine layers like powdered
charcoal to the sole and sides of my
boots I only go in a small fraction of
an inch maybe an eighth of an inch but I
can see the footprints of my boots and
the treads in the fine sandy particles
after coming back from the moon and
spending a couple of weeks in quarantine
to make sure that he had not picked up
any alien cooties
Armstrong then wins on a major publicity
tour promoting NASA and the lizard
people agenda serving as the deputy
associate administrator for aeronautics
for the office of Advanced Research and
technology and then not long after that
in 1971 he left NASA from there
Armstrong lived a mostly quiet life said
John Glenn of this Armstrong doesn't
feel that he should be out Huck stirring
himself he was a humble person and
that's the way he remains after his
lunar flight as well as before beyond
keeping a mostly low profile he among
other things taught aerospace
engineering at the University of
Cincinnati helped investigate space
flight accidents and acted as a
spokesman and/or board member for
various businesses ever the Explorer in
1985 Armstrong went on a little trip
with Edmund Hillary the first person
along with Tenzing Norgay to summit
Mount Everest Steve Fossett first person
to fly around the world non-stop doing
it in a balloon and separately in an
airplane and Patrick Mauro the first
person to summit each of the tallest
mountains in Asia Africa North America
South America Antarctica Europe and
Australia so what did this illustrious
group of explorers do together well they
took a jaunt to the North Pole
presumably using Armstrong's connections
with NASA to get access given NASA
closely guards the giant icy wall
they're keeping it from the public eye
in order to maintain
the deception that the earth isn't
flattest is plain as day to anyone with
eyes for on this go see our video on our
sister channel today I found out
why do people think the earth is flat
and that was a bonus fact when Neil
Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin stepped out
onto the moon all those years ago
literally everything they did became a
record because everything they did that
day was the first time in human history
someone had done something on the moon
for example after Aldrin joined
Armstrong on the surface of the Moon the
pair became the first hop like a
kangaroo on the moon for science now you
see NASA wasn't entirely sure about how
astronauts should move around on the
moon since they could only theorize
about how lower gravity would affect
their movements and balance such the
power ask to experiment with different
ways of moving to discern the most
efficient method of getting from point A
to point B for future astronauts
initially NASA had assumed that the best
way to move around on the moon would be
to use small double footed jumps not
unlike a kangaroo
however Aldrin and Armstrong found this
way of moving awkward and unnatural and
both astronauts found it easier to move
in a much more conventional manner
hopping from one foot to the other
Armstrong nicknames this way of moving
the loop as for the first meal on the
moon this consistent of bacon cookies
and coffee along with some peaches and a
glass of grapefruit juice if he hopes
the bacon part of the meal was the first
item eaten on the moon well we're sorry
to disappoint you
contrary to what you'll often read a
very small something was eaten shortly
before the meal and that was communion
bread eaten by Buzz Aldrin shortly after
landing on the surface before Aldrin set
off on the Apollo 11 mission he took
within a small communion kid Givens hymn
by Reverend Dean Woodruff so that he
could symbolically take part in the
ceremony with the other members of his
Presbyterian Church this kit contained a
small piece of communion bread and a
small vial of wine both of which Aldrin
consumed after saying a prayer during
the Apollo 11 radio blackout this was
also unsurprisingly the first religious
service held on the moon Aldrin had
initially plans to share his communion
prayer with the people of Earth but NASA
requested at the last minutes that he
not do this in order to avoid offending
people not of the Christian faith as it
happens when the crew of Apollo 8 had
read a passage from Genesis Aldrin
agreed and instead perform the ceremony
privately while Armstrong respectfully
observed Buzz Aldrin also took another
first away from Neil and that was being
the first person to year
on the moon so if when take that mr.
Armstrong and if you're thinking just
now that this isn't nearly as brave as
being the first person to step out onto
the moon and into the black void of
space you should probably know that the
urine collection system on the lunar
module had to be pressurized to ensure
that the astronauts weren't injured
while peeing it was noted in the Apollo
experience report that a prime urine
transfer design constraint for the lunar
module was that the crewmen would be
protected at all times from pressure
differentials this system however was a
little buggy at first NASA engineers
being NASA engineers they worked out all
the kinks in the end but let's not
discount the bravery of being the first
man to use the extreme suction device on
the lam and now for another bonus fact
speaking of Buzz Aldrin's mother's name
before getting married was Mary Ann moon
as for his nickname buzz Edwin Eugene
Aldrin got their name due to one of his
older sisters this was Faye Ann Aldrin
mispronouncing brother as buzzer she was
a year and half old when Buzz was born
rather than call him 'junior or maleic
his father's name was also edwin eugene
Aldrin buzzer was shortened to buzz and
became his chosen moniker for the rest
of his life in 1988 Aldrin even made it
official by legally changing his name hi
again Simon here if you enjoyed this
video please do consider go and
subscribing to highlight history where
this video originally aired if you liked
it there is a link in the description
below and thank you for watching